welcome to the recruitment rollercoaster
podcast my name is Hisham azuz I'm in a
nother we work getting less and less
excited to come to these if I'm honest
it's the same and I'm joined today by
Alex stone who is a country director for
Orbis and alex is heading up the
american division for a bit that's right
yeah
Alex thank you for joining me my
pleasure as I've said as I send to you
where I always like to start is how how
did Alex stone from ethics get into
recruitment
well so I started off as a personal
trainer ok then I changed I changed
careers got into Events Management in
London ok which is something I always
want to get into what Events Management
yeah really Events Management promoter
it wasn't promoting it was more like
location management so he says Parker
films like dark night we'd hear
PlayStation game launches already some
really cool stuff but it doesn't pay
money it's kind of made for people that
are already rich yeah one of my friends
my old school friends yeah college
friends I was in recruitment ma'am
and that's Craig okay he was hurt oh six
yeah I remember the point I think was on
the train one day and it was something
he was going to barley for a holiday and
I was going to I wanted to have a piece
of that I mean he got me an interview
with a company he worked at who at a
time was my my football manager really
coincidentally and went in there and got
the job and went from there okay what do
you know anything about recruit I was
going to say what was your perception
like I had no idea that really had the
reputation it did
what you had to do about it I didn't
completely blown off the wind how they
sell it you what's there you mate so I
can imagine there'd be a bit more honest
and say that I came from reasonably hard
at school so I was negotiating contracts
and my job before and used to working
the money side of it yeah understanding
emotions and yeah people work and not
this at all related to recruitment I but
you've been in those types of situations
and all that what they were selling I
could relate to so yeah it just kicked
off really yeah they just said yeah
coming this give me a quick and how long
is it you there for just to sort of set
there yeah so Craig was my friend and
there was there was about three or four
teams and individuals of running the
team yeah and Craig was working on a
different scene to see my joint Wayne
was running the team I joined
okay who's it's a Craig and Wayne just
let it run now and understand that
because you probably refer to them a
couple of times today obviously founded
Orbison now they obviously the business
that you're part of and work for and
also part as well yeah is it perfect
so then sir then how long did you work
in that first of equipment job for
chewing our fries two and a half three
years and then after that you then left
all this waited now and it's been what
five you said five and half years yeah
I'm five and a half years so it was
going for two and off years and the
company just got smaller and smaller at
36 really people just leave in and yeah
it was one of those typical recruitment
companies where I joined I joined we had
two massive accounts to be no financial
services accounts yeah they were just
giving us so many roles against five or
six other agencies portal driven
recruitment that stopped it was
basically the first come first serve
really so you said financial services
was in the market that you operate and
now what we normally do financial
services but in the last three years
we've we've I'd say we're more just
covering the whole of Digital side so
when you got into recruitment you did UX
did you start in that honour no I didn't
I did all see sharp engineering okay so
they're slightly different obviously
different well he did know
was itwas yeah and then we fell I've
been doing UX equipment for about seven
of the eight and a half years I've been
doing OH so for a long time we first
started to see UX role was coming out
and it's narrow I was that's a
particular shine to really under this is
the old days of Morgan Stanley built the
matrix platform and all the other banks
want this jump on it UBS obvious ones
jump on what not now anyway so you
believe that so I am I went down the the
UX Avenue and yeah just just push that
and hope to grow that out yeah
from day one really and when we moved
over here
it was UX grew into just digital yeah
with web world and design okay
yeah just quickly I know you said that
you doesn't have the best memory if you
can't remember everything that's fine
but I do always like to ask people like
you can talk about it for the whole
experience but like how are those first
copy is for you in recruitment cuz I
know he said literally went into it
Brian you had no idea like you just
working working out as you went along
but like was it difficult like did you
find it tough and these things because I
had a very difficult first year in
recruitment but I openly say on here but
like how were your sort of first year
two years in recruitment they would self
like I said you know there was a portal
driven experience sitting there sitting
on database I think which is even pretty
LinkedIn so really it's a free database
is going through try and pinch other
people with hot lists yes that was that
star was pretty cutthroat really um
which I guess made me may book me into
the recruitment cruiser that I am today
well the opposite of that just wow
just giving you thick-skinned originally
when you first start yeah ready to
survive because I call that what the
percentages but a lot of people quit in
the first 12 my was that everyone meant
lows loved one and for people I think
I've heard yeah loads of places yeah so
um it was it was hard work but I've
never really chased down the growth of
it it was just I was just spoon-fed
roles were driven had to get there get
around go find it meet the business
always out on on meetings trying to grow
right
Vidhya where is that I was given to
specialize into UX side of it and so
when did this when did when did you when
was it less so when he was building up
the UX piece was it less being spoon-fed
stuff and that was that when things
start to change
phew yeah it was it was because I think
I was one of the first within financial
services anyway that was really took on
- Oh as a as a as a company especially
we joined Orbis yeah started to realize
that it wasn't that saturated of a
market yeah comparison huge advantages
yeah it was just an area that was like
somewhat is and we managed to tap onto
it pretty early on yeah and the business
backed it and we just we went for it and
did it helped it helped having that
nation as it using it as a battering ram
to get into a fact that we only do that
that matter who helps than that yeah ok
so then basically what was did you did
you always have the I guess when you
enter this world a recruitment like did
you ever think about being at
potentially your own and part of your
own recruitment business and stuff like
that you know I mean or is it all just
sort of quite evolved organically and
sort of naturally quite happened because
you've got these really good
relationships with Craig and Wayne and
all these things you know I mean how did
you ever think about that sort of to
free is in because it's free and a half
easy was there yeah that was you know
the thing is company-owned are free it's
really a two and a half three years so
like yeah like what did you think about
potentially having your own recruitment
business and like that or was it just no
I mean I actually went when all this
whatsoever in 36 I left for a few six
and the waning Craig sorts out there and
company you asked me and one other to go
and work for them yeah we just those two
with the main people with that company
really yeah and if we knew we knew if
they were leaving at that point actually
Craig had left was in working Hong Kong
for a couple of years and so I think is
when said to craig this this Duren thing
leave leave Hong Kong mm-hmm and come
back and star on company up and they
poached me and me Nick over and was over
if her I've been in the US for a couple
years now a year and a half yeah and um
it's obvious wasn't my company yeah so I
am I
I moved over to the USU and i'ma go and
meet Wayne and Craig decided to open up
the business which is like I said
December 17 okay cool all right then
well let's break down a bit before you
got to that point because like joining
the business obviously you've got really
good relationships with these people
which massively helps but yeah just you
being you for like whether you start
with your shoe fall in like this small
room just like pinging it out like what
it was it was a classic stop it was I
remember unboxing the computers first
they just like what do we I think Wayne
bought on a first big client who had a
good relationship with and we just um
grew out from there did a good job with
that one client which is always the way
to do business I think and do a job with
one client yeah Gangu growing too and
did you continue down the UX rule was
that whatever at that point no it was
you know it was we were happy to just
get first rolling yeah I think there's a
c-sharp rolling yeah and then you know
great I forgot a lot of concepts when
working in the inner space for a long
time and yeah we just opened it out
really from there yeah
was it it was it was hard graft for the
first
Watauga offers for the first 12 months
it was picking up and running with it
really yeah was it what you expected um
it was exciting yes super exciting we
was in there and like a shared office
space amongst in a couple of companies
nothing like we work and it must have
been it must have been fun because like
obviously some nice to do with people
that obviously you know outside of it
sort of their work world you know I mean
that's also added took you all and the
sort of journey together and you're
trying to build something lighting
specialist to where it got to now but
that must have helped sure they sort of
to know each other like that yeah it was
it was we're all mates so it was I'm
sure there's also some trouble with that
as well wasn't I say so so then that
year that first year at Orbis was you on
the tools' the whole time
why would you object yeah yeah yeah
absolutely I mean it's only been up
until the last I'd say two years that
I've taken a bit more of a step back off
the tools yeah I still get involved now
yeah if there's something obvious which
I need to jump on but um yeah it was it
was cutting teeth grind desk you know
work I'm sort of ours to fill it just
grow out the company and then I think in
the first I think it's in the first six
months we we actually brought another
chap over there was there was another
chap that would come over from 33:6
and then he left to go through a
master's degree and then he come back
and we started to grow growing on that
and do you when do you when do you start
then growing up did you have your own
team did you end up having your own team
I didn't have my my I didn't stop
growing my team until probably the turn
off using really I'd say maybe two using
so you just really really get in the
kalam relation it's locked in for
yourself building your network
candidates clients for that yeah yeah I
mean you know we need to start getting
someone the underneath your belt when
you're starting to pick up too many
roles well a lot of roles that you need
some support on which you can give
guidance on and everyone that was there
from the beginning we just we had enough
on that we could start getting people
into sports which you guys that was
pretty early on that was within the
first year yeah yeah in but my team I
think was in the second year really yeah
so how so how was you what was I know it
again this may sound really basic but I
think I'll tell you before like one of
the most common things people was asked
me about is and the I find it really
difficult is when you're early on trying
to build out a desk and these things
right I know you came from a previous
company and probably leveraged that
after your restrictive covenants or
whatever but like what how did you
approach building that business do you
know I mean was it just in terms of was
you how did you approach getting more
and more clients getting more and more
people knowing about all this and these
things like because that might have been
tough at the beginning right no one
would have known who August was right
yeah of course well I mean we all add
other than me at Wayne Kragen Nick
there's another chapter ones at Camilla
was is next brokered a lot of
relationships in
in industry okay once you've been in
industry for a certain amount time you
have a lot of relationships yeah people
typically want to work with the
individual rather than yeah typically so
that organically just grew us out within
a reasonably short space of time
yeah and that's how we grew the company
out and they should really grow I need
any discount but how did you approach it
the same thing I mean I'd be an
improvement for a couple of years and
after doing a good job with one client
they recommended me to another client
and getting around industry verse
biddies that I'm meeting up with
candidates which she flits it's a
classic recruitment methods yeah never
really went down the specking in route
really no we're never really had we
never really had to I know it's like a
great tool but um we were working with a
lot of big accounts that were feeding us
a lot of roles hmm so that's not
typically I mean if we had a absolute
cork with a candidate and you knew it's
an obvious it's bigger than we did so
but it was never a bday sit down and
send out so okay cool so then so then
how did you sort see before you join
Orbis did you manage anyone before
no yeah yeah the chap I said went to his
masters alright joint and and what it
might seem so I had one chap underneath
me yeah and we helps go out a desk of 36
really bruised company okay cool so you
had a bit of experience before yeah
really because I guess how did you fund
how did you find that transition because
light typically again a big challenge
for recruiters is they might be really
really good builders and they're like
whoever whoever they're their manager is
or whatever the Lapp great Alex let's
make two more Alex's or three more alex
is right that's the plan mine so I guess
how did you find that as you were
building out your your team and not just
worrying about your own Billings but
then all of a sudden you're managing
people and these things how did you find
that yeah I mean it was kind of fun
started to do well and you know managers
I think typically when you start to do
well from a billing since they think
okay he's ready to start building his
own team out yeah and in hindsight it's
probably a bit premature really yeah
definitely I mean you you need to ask
what that's really common though yeah is
recruitments success in recruitment is I
guess how much money you put in the
board yeah whether you're ready to start
growing at email is different yeah you
need to use a map out what the best
route is for you if you want to go down
that that principal top billing route
went to start growing around seeing now
and you had someone come and come join
me and it naturally just went into it to
grind him out and give him role with me
going out and being kind of forced to go
out and give him positions and your CSS
resource he's just resource in spinister
yeah nobody was helping him out bringing
him success which was to bring you
success yeah and these things then how
many people did you grow your team to
then at 36 it was just the one mmm and
then we left
yeah yeah then when you start building
into him all based like two years in or
whatever what did you that what is the
team now like how many people have you
going it to well I used to look after
digit would see when I was in the UK and
we go up to five people in my team oh
really
yeah and then I moved to the US within
the digital team it was just you know
everything that from from UX to
front-end engineering and then as you so
just quickly before when we talk about
the whole us piece like when you had
five in your team's I'm gonna do just to
help me out was you always billing at
that point yeah I was a brilliant
manager really which is always something
it's a it's a it's a challenge when you
just start off trying to grow numbers up
and and get one else's numbers up when
you're feeding a desk and at the time
the business model was an ID quite a few
big accounts as I was feeding feeding
the team yeah um so the idea at that
point was just there were resources and
now those guys are 360 recruiters
clients but for a good proportion of me
managing that team isn't me just feeding
the team yeah CCS are doing growing them
out to understand you
I've been flipping candidates and yeah
so was that a challenge for you
maintaining your numbers then while she
was managing at that point during that
period yeah you always do a second tip
you know if you start taking on say
maybe I mean you probably notice if you
take one more higher on you you probably
see a dip in that mom you look at you
know like a graph so how did you get
better at managing that then because I
think there's some good stuff in that
make where a lot of people will be
trying to go through that because it's
not easy as it's like how did you get
better that no doubt you probably wasn't
too great at the beginning but like how
did you get better at it and what things
did you learn through that
well you just being organized yes I
start to take my organization my daily
organization a lot more seriously after
I think the the surreal in higher yeah
because when you start getting you know
two three people on your belt then it's
a big difference is that because it is
so easy for them to take time from you
if you go I mean it's LA ilex can you
help me this Alex can help with that you
know I mean yeah of course yeah not just
that but you want to try and grow them
as well and start teaching him of
bringing their own clients in and
spotting a lead and actually getting out
there and building relationships and
building their own personal brand rather
than spoon-feeding
yeah it breeds a I think a bad recruit
if they just gonna sit there and welcome
any more so so let's talk a bit about
that because I think there's some good
stuff in there so you've got a serious
prove managing your time so what did you
work where would you like losing times
you're going to get I mean what did you
what did you get sort of better out in
terms of managing the time what did you
change to really enable you to get hold
of your time better as Alex or the
billing manager not just reacting every
time someone's got a question making
sure you setting time aside to sit down
with people um is probably the key thing
really yeah I mean people have a day job
needs to be get on with things right
yeah I've watched it's just too
disruptive mmm so sitting time aside
with with each person and giving them
that your undivided attention and when
you do book in that time
as opposed to looking at some of people
and I'm not necessarily one for
micromanaging so jumping on top of
people making sure they're gonna keep
you up kpi's we're not necessarily a
hardcore KPI driven yeah company course
owls hmm he don't strongly that me know
so we just thought it was it was just
about splitting your day up making sure
you're organized on a daily basis yeah
him your basic kpi's from not series out
yeah was anything else in that you
really started to change or implemented
in your days as a building manager that
really helped you keep up with the
numbers and not take as much as did when
you had another person these things
anything us and besides time management
I mean this is a relationship game so ok
making sure you're you're not just
sitting there doing admin all day not
being distracted from replying to emails
all day and and out there growing the
business and your own your own desk
making sure that you're making an effort
yeah that change of mindset turning it
from a chore thinking I've got me this
person to this is what I need to do to
this desk and that was a big change I
mean that eat that nursery is a big
change and what the mindset yeah yes but
you know but I'm successful manager yeah
you should be out half a day every day
or at least a good good proportion of
the day and finally I was going on the
market so on top of keeping organized
making sure you out there building
relationships finding that was going on
keeping on top of trends and is that
because then it's gonna help you I guess
help them grow the team because you
doing that is gonna enable you to grow
the guys underneath you and stuff like
that yeah absolutely of course yeah if
you're out there meeting people and
taking the guys along with you yeah to
essentially pass that relationship over
mmm it's going to push yeah I'm talking
about grads you know guys that come in
from from from the ground up they don't
know I spell equipment is completely cuz
I guess that couldn't to be a challenge
isn't if like you you win that will you
win an account and
have a really good relation you do pass
it on to John who's now on your team and
it's like wow okay well where's Alex
gone is it too good to speak to us now
from the client perspective to get Y min
that's very true yeah that is true
it's is that how you approach that then
I guess how did you approach that you
always looking at the person you going
to me mm-hm and if you are it's not
going to be worth your time necessarily
holding certain Malaysian ships they're
all obviously there's some relationships
yeah especially you till winter we were
senior people that you need to keep hold
of because you might put a lot of time
into these are people yeah you can't be
glitter and those relationships because
that's gonna slowly but surely fizzle
out but getting people out there
learning from you and she'd always
obviously learn from people that are
more senior from him and I'm everyone's
constantly learning from hmm welcome to
people that are better than you all got
more experience than you so bringing
them with you even if you did have that
hand that relationship over just to work
understand how you work yeah something
we just lower yourself bossing over yeah
okay and just out of interest me
obviously don't have to like give me all
your all your secrets but is so
basically did them had a conversation I
think I referred to you referred him to
earlier but Michael James is one of the
things that he learned a business it
worked for a short time the big big big
bill is talking 500 K plus in this
agency that work for a short period of
time one of the key things that you
learn and notice was they will have big
accounts at least one big account right
and I thought that was really
interesting no one's actually sort of
pointed that out before and he said
earlier obviously about that you you you
built some big accounts right and
traditionally you've worked on accounts
that fed you a lot of jobs and stuff so
I guess how have you gone about if I'm a
recruit listening right now and I'm like
wow okay so who firstly who are the
people in my market that could be a big
accounts in these things but I said I
guess like there's a whole longer-term
approach that you have to take to try
and get these big accountants on board
or really get to that point where you're
getting a lot of business from them to
get my min so I guess just from your
experience and if you do work with some
big accounts it sounds like you do is
that fair yeah any advice on my
to navigate to start getting getting
more business from these people start
winning some big accounts or getting
them involved in your recruitment deaths
or your recruitment business well the
only real way you gonna get into a big
account like a blue chip mmm is having a
very good relationship with someone very
senior there's wincing the neck out okay
if you're gonna anyway if you're gonna
approach tan acquisition or HR of them
so HR people know I mean if you're going
in there coal they're gonna have their
template to say they're not you know
reviewing their PSO until next year it's
very classic
that's it response and so you have to
really go in there with someone that
wants a higher okay and the manager
needs to be willing to say this is you
wanna hire its through and so is that
being traditionally how you've got in
with these these big accountants you
build some really good relationships
with people that as you said are willing
to say to whoever internally well a lot
actually really need this person like
I'd really appreciate if we could I
don't know get them to jump through some
hoops or whatever that would really
benefit me and my team because I've got
this this person I really need or
whatever has that typically been the
route that you've gone down there yeah
every time really every time it has to
be otherwise okay you're just gonna get
put in a pile yeah it's probably never
gonna seen it be seen what what's like
what's the from your experience in like
what's a good way or the best approach
to find out what these people need
obviously gonna know your market but
like are you keeping an eye on
okay so such and such company of
advertised for this blah blah blah and
you know I mean I'm sure it's gonna be
candidates that are gonna be sought
after in smaller businesses anyway
you're gonna know the skill sets that
people really want but like how do you
like how do you keep an eye on what
these people people really need that are
gonna be willing to well alex has got
this person I must like put stick Mon
that cut forward you know I'm in
how do identifiers that well if you're
not talking directly to the hiring
manager hiring someone and then you know
Corey game speaking to a couple of
people in their team use mmm yeah you
might call someone for reverse be then
just so I've got it's always wrong so
much grass be there
what you mean Oh as in life so speak to
senior speech I can that I seen your
candidate it's about someone in that
scene you're targeting you have mapped
out this particular coin this is if you
don't know the ultimate decision-maker
yeah yeah are not to free people to
speak something about future roles and
find out what's going on in their thing
yeah what the issues are why they're
looking and find a rockstar that you can
then maybe speak into the lobby a
rockstar net so that generally that's
been how you so I guess if you're
attacking something yes if you know that
if you've mapped out there's this
there's a huge business where it should
[ __ ] get a piece of that pie it's
gonna really benefit more in recruitment
business and recruit me this yeah and
then I guess after that it's like rinse
and repeat you call really deliver and
again it's coming back to providing a
really good service and being good at
what you do but that's that's some real
practical advice this helps you get into
big accounts yeah definitely yeah okay
interesting so I guess let's talk a bit
about why did you move to America um I
started doing a lot of business over
there really yeah so before move out
it's two years lead not so it starts to
do quite a bit business over there with
some big big names again yeah and some
of those clients were ones that were
working with in the UK that naturally
said can you hire for me in the US I was
gonna say how did you approach you did
you so how long was that period before
we went to America how much light yeah
how long was a period where you was
doing business from the UK in America
before about two years really
yeah lead natsu it's about two more was
that a conscious decision like it was
yeah in the back of my head always
wanted to UM I always loved America and
really left for my kids yes always had
this interest of doing business over
there not that I necessarily started off
thinking that I was gonna move over
there and said yeah but you like to make
a trip over there from time to time and
yeah that's sort of routine and then and
they got to a point where we're doing so
much business out there it was a
no-brainer executive decision to just
quickly then again think not of people
listening I think we've seen obviously
before that obviously and recruiters I'm
sure it's commonly read aware
you can move to America there's bigger
fees you can earn a lot more money the
word recruitment and recruiter is
perceived in a different way over there
all this if I'm a farmer you can recruit
right now on i'm i recognized that the
sector that i'm in and the businesses I
work with do have American arms and
there are opportunities they do have
business in America in these things did
that happen quite naturally or how did
you I'm sure maybe happen naturally but
also how did you then proactively
cultivate the opportunities to place
people in America with the clients you
had in UK how did you approach that well
if you're working with a big brand you
know they've got offices I mean if you
work with a client you should know where
yeah yeah sure whether um sell offices
are yeah or the headquarters um yeah
yeah and conversations just come up if
you've got a good relationship you
should have good relations yes so um you
should understand what that's what their
wishes are what whether whether things
are globally mm-hmm if I say they're in
New York then you propose your they come
to you you know if you're doing a good
job which you know you should be then
okay so no I know it sounds simple based
like ask absolutely ask yeah um yeah do
you know a lot of time they'll suggest
you can you know is there something you
can do Alex yeah so how did you approach
her though cuz I'm sure obviously it
appeared you haven't done it before do
you say that I have done it before but I
can probably my bat myself to deliver
and find people like or did you just say
yeah I can do that do not mean yeah well
that you can you assume that time knows
you can deliver yeah and you've got a
good enough relationship with you where
he always turns to you to recruit for
them then you if he says he's hiring
overseas and you say yes I can do it you
can always got a jump on it even if you
necessarily can't succeed you go give it
a go yeah nine times that saying if
you're a good recruiter you're gonna
fill the role yeah don't necessarily
have to be in that location to fool the
wrong with a lot of settle offices
around the world or in canoes I did
business I think the last the final year
of me working in the US when I was based
in the UK about 80 percent of the work I
was doing was in the u.s. really yeah
which goes to show that you don't need
to be based in education and why is that
do you think like why you don't need to
be based in that like obviously there's
benefits or being in the location but
why do you think that because a lot of
people would say that wouldn't they be
like Alex but how could I do that from
the UK and like you know I mean like so
like why do you why do you think that
that's easily it is achievable because
clearly you did it you know I mean yeah
I mean there's lots of recruitment
companies though doing European
equipment not only work in Germany or
Scandinavian it's a technology long as
you can work the hours because you might
have to stay up an extra five hours
sometimes yeah we have to make sure
we're on conference calls or arranging
things at certain hours most of
equipments a life that wasn't your most
recruiters they're answering emails at
the weekends or just fully get into bed
and missus with all that man
so I guess a few things on that then
because leur again thinking other people
listening and what what what were
firstly what was some of the again it
seems like it went well but what were
some of the challenges that you have to
overcome will get better with when you
first started doing more American
business like how do people receive Alex
stone from the UK calling me from UK but
it's about jobs in America whatever - no
I mean like what were some of the
challenges that I guess you've got
better--it and solving and these things
as you're doing more and more American
business what are some of the things
that you came up with against early on
well I mean generally I find us
equipment a lot easier then London
recruitment really a lot more receptive
to reply to you your emails why is that
because that isn't the first time I've
heard that
no yeah so why is that do you think um
just because I think recruitments looks
that differently over there
how's it looked in the UK it's such a
saturated market that these guys get
handed all day every day
yeah and in the UK I don't think they
necessarily look it at it's as a as a
sales job or as a as a as a pest that
hounded me all the time I really I think
it looks at as a necessary function
really oh they have different job so I
was over there so I that's why I called
a country director country Doris
you know this interesting look so how
did that help them did that mean that it
enabled to build relationships quickly
it enabled you to ya get influence
people well it other night you know I
mean how did that help how did that
perception help you know I mean how did
that help you and just because you know
you're making a lot of traction over
there with people that were answering to
to your calls and that naturally
progresses into oh by the way I'm hiring
and yeah that that balloons out into
more clients and more opportunity and
but because people are more open to
recruitment over there were speaking to
recruiters it's just that it's a
different world to be honest that yeah
guys Farhad
yeah okay there's definitely dive into
that when obvious to talk about when you
move down and stuff but I guess so then
in terms of like just how curiosity for
me like was your like video and calling
people stuff or was it all a lot of
predominant done over the phone I think
one video call yeah oh so I've never
also recruited in your market but like
so obviously you obviously you would
have been good at understanding if
someone's good or not but was that would
that that never become a challenge and
sort of really gauging if someone was
good just over a phone call obviously
was a challenge you know it's not
looking at whites or someone's off
that's what I mean it's always gonna be
difficult
yeah and that and that's why most
businesses I mean that's why the UK
businesses are flooding the US shores in
a moment but and it's not absolutely
necessary again it goes back to when
he's recruiting companies that do
European equipment and so will you have
a group and they're based here in the UK
mm-hmm it still works okay yeah okay
mate said to wrap to wrap that up mmm
Alex farmer if I'm a UK recruiter right
now I've identified there is an
opportunity to get some more American
business my clients have told me that
definitely I need help in America blah
blah blah what's like your go-to advice
for people if they want to start
building out more of an American more of
an American market in terms of get to
that point where eight percent of its
they could move over whatever do not I
mean so firstly I guess you would would
you definitely recommend doing a good
stint before you went over there as
opposed to like going over there then
starting yeah you have to I think you're
setting yourself up for
not every time but I know a lot of
people have moved over there to a cold
cold up cold and they're struggling so
you need to have some kind of foundation
over there some some business already
moving to to grow up on okay but if you
have an opportunity to do that then my
advice is jumping it really yeah well I
did say I'm gonna be chance tonight yeah
okay
and then um she moved over there so
you've lived in what what where do you
live
Brooklyn really yeah we're based in
Brooklyn and I think most of the guys
are about other than one is in Manhattan
but yeah it's the cool part of town
really yeah and how many of you guys how
many people in your team not in America
there are eight of us serving the UK as
well who are gonna be moving over okay
so yeah so they're doing a bit similar
to what you did then yeah well they just
started with us so okay that make sense
okay
so I mean firstly mate let's talk a bit
about obviously boy from Essex living in
Brooklyn what's missing Brooklyn lost
that like mad we're recruitment can take
your corner you know you never never
think that no no you digging into my
past makes you think when I first
thought I didn't even know a
conversation which ended up in me living
in Brooklyn yeah yeah it's obviously
awesome it's a great career to get into
mmm although all that negative
reputation that woman has that God gets
I think it's a great job mmm really yeah
actually think that yeah yes she's
traveling the world whether you live
somewhere and if you're doing overseas
recruitment you need to go in you always
out not just sitting behind a desk all
day meeting people when it's a it's a
people's game mmm it Brookins the right
place what have been what have been some
of those little key differences that
you've had to get used to that living in
Brooklyn living in America cost of
living is a big one really really a lot
more expensive more expensive yeah I'd
go as far as saying if double if not
triple that what you're used to spending
in the UK but then Sally's reflect that
what you earn reflects that a sense what
a fees are so big over there
and why are they so big ladies actually
is that generally true that the feeds
are bigger over there 100% yeah well I
mean you people earn more money so
you're - what salaries are higher
salaries are higher but not just that I
mean the UK industry your clients a lot
of clients try and push people down
whereas in the u.s. they're pretty open
to much higher percentages from 25 to 35
percent switch and UK you never really
hear of that too much oh my god you
definitely don't know so and with itself
no because you know it's just classic in
its like got a recruiter down Valon pub
Gagne America's great lover blob it's
like is it really wrong it's hard yes
yes it's not it's not easy it's all
especially if you're just sitting up
over there and think about moving moving
over but I think if you've been doing
recruitment for a while in the UK and
you're thinking of moving over there
you're used to quite a lot of knock
backs in the UK mm-hmm so one of those
over there it's the equivalent of yeah a
lot more it's like if I thought so I
mean the whole living there and these
things like if I'm if I'm a UK recruit
right now and a rhetorics in my egg and
look there's this amazing opportunity
New York blah blah blah mmm what should
I be thinking about because you're
you're 18 months in that living there
yeah yeah so what what should I be
thinking about that the retros not
telling me about you know I mean
definitely try and get some kind of a
conversation tied in really first anyway
well if you never spend much time in New
York you don't know where to live you're
not just going it's difficult with
finding a home they typically go with
into there two or three days under that
quick yeah property's not on the market
for long so that so basically if you can
if if you can get some sort of
accommodation so I just let one less
thing to worry about
yeah it's not they make sure you just
set yourself a hotel and air B&B for the
first month and then and then discover
where you want to live and jump at any
opportunity to move into a place that
you like the look of and just explore
the areas because Manhattan itself huge
Brooklyn's it's huge a lot people and
consists of five boroughs although most
people we believe in Queens or Brooklyn
or Manhattan even Harlem so what would
you would you recommend people to
actually before they accept any sort of
job there and if it actually trying to
experience it at least of all a lie yeah
if you've never been before you need to
go out there and really experience it
yeah try and understand how is it
compared to London yeah yeah whoever's
completely different extremes winters
are really cold
I've heard it smells said New York
absolute thing maybe on a lot of the
subways I know I mean that's sort of it
the cost of living how busy is it oh
because everyone everyone has a
perception of London is like chaos
bubble rubber again New York is like
another level but like everyone's just
like them no one no one no one look see
each other it's just like that that's
what the typical
perception of it you know I mean yeah i
say Manhattan's very close to that
really it yeah but Brooklyn's a lot more
you get a lot more time lot more space
really green space where is Manhattan's
obviously an island and it's some of the
areas are just like Leicester Square
really flashing lights and people
pushing each other past and yellow cabs
being everywhere they're not shy but
over to really being everywhere and yeah
okay so be now 18 months yeah I guess
how how much of an impact has it had in
terms of you living over there now and
obviously continuing to build this
business as it helped me so obviously
now you've moot because obviously you
built it before you went there now being
over there has actually helped you grow
it better have you is it maybe to meet
more people build more relationships
like has it has it given you sort of a
real positive to continue grow and grow
and a team over there actually been over
there yeah yeah well I mean as I said
you need you need to have some kind of
foundation to go over there upon and and
I've been doing it about two years
before so because I've done that had
some people to start meeting women
leading up to years I'll come out every
quarter so I knew these people
reasonably well who knew so yeah and at
that point you can start hiring managers
move to other companies and they take
you along with them yeah
need to have something to move into I
think I think that's pretty critical
being successful over there
thank you wrong there's some awesome
crews out there yeah could hit the
ground running from from day one and do
some concordant but being on the ground
how does it helped you know I mean I've
now been in America in New York like has
it helped you a lot yeah yeah of course
you being out scare they don't get that
face time you know that's that
relationship so I'd rather than just
being it on the phone a number yeah over
the phone or standing email that
replying to me that's how that's how
business is done
mm mm how I've always done busy so we've
always done business or yeah it's a
relationship-driven job so yes it's
really important I'm currently get since
I'm over there and then I think you said
so then for the last light to turn a bit
years do you say you have been a bit
less involved in terms of light Billings
or what like just be a bit more
hands-off that right yeah I have been I
have been
yeah just helping to everything I mean
the team around us all senior over there
so everyone's kind of running their own
their own desks but some of the accounts
we've got pretty big so it's about um
yeah I mean I'm over there and from an
Operations standpoint from a client
relationship management standpoint so
I've been I'm gonna be wrong I still get
hands-on if is there while we want to
jump on if I know the right person for
the role yeah but yeah have you found
that that and there's that been has that
been a sort of an interesting transition
is that something that you wanted wanted
today yes it's um it's kind of been
moving towards that for a little weather
yeah
yeah I mean I've definitely noticed you
on you less and less hands on so get my
hands involved yeah yeah I guess what
I'd love to sort of dive into a bit mate
before we sort of start wrapping up and
stuff like obviously how have you done
Billings wise done all right
yeah yeah yeah what's been your best
year last year is our first full year um
in the u.s. I told mom it's been based
over there so we moved over I'm Lutheran
cemetery thing as another chap you start
just before me over there who'd worked
before and yeah 36 um so yeah she
fascinating was our first first of all
how'd you do good good at 600 really
yeah that's no joke that mate what's the
first year that's a real NASA brew
that's legit yeah maybe that's no joke
that's class that's amazing right
actually first year we've done well yeah
yeah well I guess part of that like
anything name do you think he's that
sort of enable used to do that I think I
think a lot of people want to think a
lot I love businesses I've I hear about
want to get as many clients as possible
as quick as possible
mmm and not focus on one core client mmm
is something we started doing last year
and last year we had and it's only until
Christmas as three of us four of us
mm-hmm
and we just focused on one real quark
line a couple of the smaller ones but
and making sure we did a good job with
that
yeah and now yeah we're halfway through
into the second year and it's called a
lot people have left Ryan and take as
long with them and raishin ships are
turning - yeah so what you're saying is
that actually as you said a lot of
people were very quick to block Rodney's
get jobs or mieze get clients for the
door blah blah blah but can sometimes be
a bit complacent with the relationship
so they probably worked really hard to
get and have that same energy as to
light at the beginning when they want it
and they win it there and not put a lot
of energy into maintaining expanding it
and growing it in terms of the key
relations they already have yeah thanks
focus on just focus on if it's a big
account yeah yeah just do a good job one
client and then when you're ready took
on a second time doing really good job
with that and then just grow out rather
than chasing yourself yeah and I guess
from from your perspective may I be
interested to hear some things around
like so the people that have been around
you mm-hmm I guess obviously now from
operations standpoint and it obviously a
big part for you now is making sure that
everyone is doing well and excelling and
these things like what what are some of
the sort of common things that you've
seen that have sort of stopped people
from taking it to the next level war
yeah that's sort of 200-300 mark or even
less than that and break to the next
level like what are some of the common
things that you've seen and you
experience people getting complacent um
people not having a speciality I think
that's critical
yeah everyone needs to have their no
role comes across the company I mean
it's it's within your discipline you
should be confident you're going to fill
that hmm and that's a good starting
point sir loads of things from Beadie to
being successful biller hmm so I think
that's some pretty important side of
being successful and on top of that it's
just again being organized keeping on
top of your day making sure you're doing
things you know the abcs follow-up
follow-ups and things in your diary and
I should get falls underneath
organizations and what is a typical
typical Alex day look like then
well sure what's your structure may
seems like you've got your organisation
down you saying that what do you would
you make like what's the tip water how
is your typical day structured get in
the morning reporting what I need to
reply to yeah yeah and and just just
make sure I'm out there on my meetings
okay so only made up a meeting though a
lot of the days I'm at the office yeah I
don't know about quarter to half a day
I'm out meeting people but they are not
out on meetings it's just them moving
things along with in client's call
people now so and I'm the account
manager of a lot of clients oh really
yeah so they do with Alex tan for a few
points yeah yeah which is a full-time
job in itself
yeah imagine any there's eight of us now
so it's me checking with guys from sighs
yeah yeah we know there any
micromanaging I say if it was pretty
don't try me and it's like you're gonna
be on my case about my cool times yeah I
know you Mary that is too much time and
effort isn't if people need watching the
managing like that is that what is that
sort of being a conscious thing again
that like it seems like if I'm if I'm
working in your team right now it's
really a lot of to you I know Alex can
help me but it's sort of um you
approached me that I'm building mines or
business within orbits and these things
is that very much is that what you're
trying to encourage these people today
yeah I mean they should be building
their own little business within a
business running their own desk and want
to grow out their reputation but that be
spoke to every hour see what they're
doing yeah no no one was to work in that
environment in my eyes I said I would
school so that's the model we have and
it works
yeah what be interested to get your
thoughts on because you see me someone
that's you're just willing to jump
straight into things and just crack on
where there's one set fit into all this
for you'd like is that something that
you've got bear at like how light have
you got better dealing with the [ __ ]
times live you've got better you know I
mean where there's mindset for in with
this or alex journey and how important
is it to you as a recruiter and as you
continue sort of developing your career
you need to be persistent and you can't
then you know a no attorney that break
you down and stop france hands room
because that's constant gonna happen if
you have that resilience and that level
of thick-skinned which how do you call
that there had you were so how did you
cultivate that mmm brush it off pocket
follow up with them again soon yeah know
that you're there to help mmm if you
feel confident that you are providing a
better solution than what they already
have then you kind of convince yourself
that's yeah how'd you get into how did
you get more of that and show guys
because know that that is a big thing
right that resilience that fake skin
it's hard right so I guess how do you
how do you sort of try and cope bear
that within your team because I'm sure
no doubt sometimes they're grab Nanak's
going may I'm just I'm getting rejected
left right and center here like I'm
struggling I'm not getting free to any
clients or I'm not being able to grow
this account or whatever like what how
would you try and call where that in
your people just 10 seconds they're back
really yeah just them do their ABCs
yes I mean if you do well you know you
shouldn't be getting too upset and
things I mean some people emotional they
may they are never really gonna change
mmm once you've you've calmed down yeah
you should you have to just follow up
and just perspective it just understand
that yeah you do get knock backs mmm
and there's plenty of business out there
hmm I think we were I think want to
speak in them earlier when you mentioned
about obviously obviously people UK
people moving over to America and
struggling and finding it hard I guess
again people people listen to this who
might be over there and it's fine as I
mentioned that guy that I live with he's
been very open about it Tom that he
moved from from London and move from the
UK to New York and like just it's just
absolute chaos
I just ate him up a live light it just
it was horrible you told me the
experience is like just it'll it just
ain't me alive I guess anyone that as my
I found themself in a bit of that
predicament obviously you are 18 months
in in now so I guess is it anything to
to share around that before we finish in
terms of anyone that you could think any
advice for for people to get over that
period or help with that period because
no doubt it's not all roses I remember
it plane is it it's gonna be tough
courses though no it's not and I guess
that goes back to my last point you just
gotta be persistent with this game no no
yay God make sure she's making sure
you're out there not just see behind in
box and did you I guess
so and I know you've said that obviously
you live with your partner over there
like obviously how important it's like
an Associated monadic because that must
be tough as well do not miss yeah that
is a massive part of it if you're just
gonna lock yourself in a bedroom when
you finish work that he's gonna eat away
at you when you know your family your
friends are back on getting yourself
involved in the American culture just
just to wrap the HeartMate this whole
American piece like what what are the
main off you from your experience you
meant you've touched on a few things but
I want to make sure that everyone
listening is sort of takes those key
takeaways but like what are the main
America what are the main differences
from being in a recruiting Americans
have been a recruit in in the UK a lot
what are their sort of main differences
that you really noticed now I've been
there from out doing it for a while oh
it's loads different words I mean from
just from the mindset of what a
recruiter is okay is is definitely
different probably the main thing really
yeah I mean recruiters taken as a
serious
there was over here is definitely a
sells chore for a recruiter because they
probably got well they more likely have
got multiple routes is not gonna door
trying to work alongside the recruiters
they are working with if it's a big
company its acquisition trying to feel
their roles I was over there it's a high
managers are open to talking to you
dominate they're open to you send him a
good profile anticipation before they're
definitely more open to giving you a
chance okay III found before when I this
someone said to me that generally um
American cultures more willing to pay
for a service and I found that I found
that really definitely found that they
give you a chance but only one chance if
you mess it up then they're probably not
gonna give you another chance they're
more open to that initial chance whereas
here it's almost a closed door and
you've gotta be more creative go around
it's so true and that's why there's so
many successful recruiters in London mmm
it's work there's a lot competition yeah
it's no saturated market London I mean
that's why the best recruiters in the
world yeah but yeah that alongside you
know things like the contract market
doesn't really exist over there like the
UK is a contract market visas need to
learn about visas cost-of-living
relocating people more willing to
relocate over there really then they ask
for something you speak to someone from
London and say in Germany not you're
probably gonna there's a lot more
hurdles to go through yeah yeah Deb
senses faces like couldn't come is now
flooding over to Ostia no it's a San
Francisco it's a Seattle or Nashville or
Chicago all these places that weren't
really on the cards did you do you
recruit predominate in its new Brooklyn
your bases you say so do you
predominately recruit in your state and
only your state or do you do stuff
outside your state and is that realistic
and achievable a decent percentage of
our work is in our state but now we work
outside of a few other states because
again going back to some clients when
you hire for me yes state and you know I
go spreading yourself too thin you want
us to specialize in your area but and
you should as well you want you want to
make sure you're owning that
yeah Geographic and I guess what I'm
just just quickly made before we
finished again just some real practical
advice like there's a whole visa
situation what's the crack there so like
if I mean UK recruit of what what do I
need
just like basics what do I need to be
able to consider a job in the American
recruitment market a company's gonna
spawn see I was is that how it works
yeah she won't be sponsored sponsored or
marry an American on tinder people
change your location yeah okay cool all
right mate well and before I finish I
would like to ask people what what what
you're excited about
so what's going on in Alex's world that
you want to shout about or what what's
going on your world that you were
excited about at the moment well I mean
I just got home to your dog it sounded
like ya got the dog back home snoop it's
mad you've you America's home now
it's early on but when you are you
excited like I mean it's definitely home
the novelty of being in America you know
it's house starts wagging when you get
to JFK oh my god I can't believe it it's
early yeah that must be man I get that
London but I'm only like a year and a
bit right do not I mean ya know I think
it took took me a year and a half for it
to start being really home and you know
you got a lot of loads of America mate I
think English yeah well I'm gonna dig
things up grand joint a couple of things
is yeah soccer teams and yeah you know
things that make up so you can go again
yeah yeah so um but yeah what were you
excited about me what's going on yeah
well I mean weird we've massively
ramping up we're growing we are in um
internal recruiter soon to help us ramp
up we're looking to open up an office in
San Francisco Texas next year um be what
you can end up moving over there or you
have to go I might maybe maybe yeah yeah
yeah kind of suffer a different space it
depends our business goes obviously yeah
yeah we're looking to open up a couple
of offices because we're doing a lot of
business in other states now as well so
look like last question I asked it to
everyone you can answer with a phrase a
sentence or
whatever comes to mind okay basically if
you could if Alex could communicate
every single recruit out there they take
on an advice they listen what do you say
um be persistent don't let things get
you down
hmm yeah a lot of people give up further
hatton after these four people that are
just starting out just them my she was
60 guns make sure you always know
learning from the best in the room keep
going
yet just don't don't get bombed about
things because if you're gonna start
frying a paddy and letting things get to
you emotionally then these probably
isn't about game for you sounds is graft
it's hard quipment knows it takes takes
a lot a lot of hours to get to a point
we need to be but if you're asking the
right questions and asking questions a
lot and don't be afraid to to go an egg
and top Billa and Oscar Mayer he's doing
it yeah that's definitely going to get
you to the next level last night that
factory time a cool we enjoyed that's
one thanks a lot